hello and welcome to this video this is
the courage for game nine of the World
Championship match between the
Challenger Sega kayaking and reigning
world champion magnus carlsen yeah game
9 is certainly a super important game
kayaking has won Game eight and is
leading the match now so Carlton has to
win a game out of these final four games
to at least level the score and yeah the
big cam had a question was before game
nine what was cousin going to do with
black heavily try something and with the
black pieces or rather stay as solid and
yeah we'll see what happens we got to be
45 and we got another Spanish so Carlton
is not trying anything let's say yeah
okay I'm saying it quite clearly nothing
wiki yeah he's not doing and 1g six or
anything of the like but rather what he
usually does play one if I play
classically however we got a slight
surprise here he goes for this variation
the yeah it has different names actually
sometimes called the newer arkhangelsk
variation the classical arkhangelsk is
this one and this was 'can replaced over
the last let's say 20 years by Bishop c5
and this is an interesting way to play
for black he plays it a bit more active
fashion than compared to them on yeah
the regular clothes druid or pestilence
where the bishop is on e 7 and usually
behind the pawn chain and here black
wants to develop this bishop more
actively it it sometimes bears
resemblance to the Italian game if white
for example now would play something
like d3 and c3 something more modest
then it would be very much like the
Italian just
Black has played b5 and after Bishop c5
en White has a number of options the
main that question for him as if he
wants to play it early a4 or not and
this nowadays is I think the main line
to play a form and here Carlton answers
Ruby eight and this is nowadays the
universally accepted may move in this
position and back a couple of years I
mean it's still seeing sometimes but
also Bishop e7 was played but in general
it is you'd with some suspicion to put
the bishop on b7 in a situation where
white can't still yeah solidify this
pawn chain here there are cases where
this is ok but it wasn't intended it in
many cases the bishop isn't all that
great down in general here Black's idea
is to pass forwarding a little bit to
put the bishop on g4 not on b7 ok this
sequence is pretty long so I'm not going
to completely skip any explanations here
so we'll see three and four white black
um is it would be unwise to take the
poor now this is going to be far too
dangerous after things like we need to
or deform so black place t6 and white
ghosty for bishop goes back to be six
and after the capture and 1983 why does
attacking on b5 an interesting point is
that white can always leave the pawn
here unprotected as black is almost
never able to take it there is always
this honey double attack by the bishop
so black is not able to attack the other
hand a black here also is a little bit
yeah yeah his piece placement is wrong
for any kind of protection of this pawn
but this is not on blacks agenda anyway
he is giving up this pawn
and tries to now get ya piece pressure
on the center as we see there is this
pinion defect which is tough tattoo to
break I mean there is no Bishop let's
say here on only two that would
naturally get break the spin and black
has nice bishop all kinds of pressure
against the senator so black is giving
out a pawn for active piece play this
line is nothing new at all there are
tons of games in the database and we see
from the time spent that both sides are
basically blitzed to this position so on
Carson um Claire played something that
um was it a total surprise let's say
this is this whole line is far too
common for that to be called a big big
surprise so it was certainly part of chi
atkins preparation and they both have
played this position from the white side
so and so what is happening here bishop
see to just one of the possibilities
black now took on g4 and light takes and
we got those trades and black took here
yeah this is one thing due to this
pressure on the pawn why does often
getting his pawn structure damaged yeah
something like this is clearly
undesirable giving up the porn that was
a game perform and leaving black with
good pieces and active active bishop and
so on so white has to live with this a
bad pawn structure and now the night
comes to age five yeah all the sunset is
well known that i DM is Queen Jeb to
have six to increase the pressure
against the pawn and potentially play
nigel form also well-known Queen Jeff
six of my notes RMS Queen gf6 Bishop e3
covering the d4 pawn and then c5 yeah we
are following a game
kayaking kayaking atoms from 2008 in
that game okay it was played but c5 is
another one that has been seen before d5
Queen to you six and takes yeah if if
black kicks on d5 white is captured here
and that doesn't look good yeah I giving
white two points so Queen two is six why
took on d6 and now the intermediate
moves c4 yeah let that make sense yeah
black wants to regain this and delay the
caption b3 and ya hear this is the
sister is known actually from a game
Nakamura cousin John of where c 3 was
the answer but the capture is also also
known and he awoke to a six yeah this is
a perfectly well known position and for
example there is a video series by Peter
Svidler who's an expert on that line on
chest 24 where he looks at this for
black and he concludes about this
position me this is part of his video
series it's not like expert knowledge
that somebody with a supercomputer might
have it's just like out there and he
concludes with with a statement this
position is not very enjoyable for black
he's a pawn down he has some
compensation probably not enough and is
definitely yeah not something very
desirable to play and so why did Carson
go for that yeah we know where he has
played all this instantly up to this
point and quite mysteriously now he took
a 30 minute think 30 minutes for Rudy
aid so this is very mysterious if you if
you I mean he played this line he
initiated
here on move 5 and i know that is move
23 but this is the absolute main road of
this it's not like this is some exotic
line where something offends something
really outlandish was played earlier on
this is just like for four players of
that level this is like bread and butter
it's nothing special and he took 30
minutes that's very surprising in fact
in the chest 24 broadcast which was
quite entertaining at this point swidler
said if Magnus is not playing a move now
in the next couple of minutes like
quickly because it's part of his
preparation he will eat his head and he
said he has a hat really unknown in the
hotel room and he would eat it in his in
the next broadcast so this will be funny
to watch tonight maybe not sure anyway
so surprisingly cards and took a long
thing here did you really forget
everything or I mean it's not possible
that he has no idea about it that would
be really strange yeah anyway mysterious
he played rugby aid so why is this
position according to swindler
unattractive or black I mean this is not
difficult to see why it is a pawn up
it's not quite clear how he how black
will get it back he has some pressure
against you for but this is a this is
the absolute best that you can might
manage that you can get the pawn back
and then yeah player drawn it is totally
playing here again of two results white
either does something with this pawn or
not you will use it somehow to pressure
and then it's a draw so black is
basically just flame playing for two
results here and the winners not one of
them so a little bit strange that that
we got into into this situation here and
yeah so what is going on white and tries
to keep his pawn and tries to activate
his bishops and correcting I think
places well very logical play group g1
putting them they look on the G file
and potentially preparing root lifts to
the fourth rank or fifth rank both both
both make some sense by the way instead
of Rupert eh maybe previous seven what's
better but this is very computer ish I
mean not the move but the whole position
is something that well as we pointed out
this is not something to play over the
board but to know because I mean it's
all theory up to this point and you
should actually precisely know what's
going on computers here are like so much
better than humans and doing all those
concrete calculation when there is no
strategic content here there is no plans
no plans no patterns whatever it just
like it's a purely mathematical exercise
to be precise trying to get the porn
back from the black site or white keep
the pawn and activate your pieces there
is no pong play for example you don't
think about structure here the structure
is already done I mean the only thing is
wife might lose this pawn or not and
this sets it and so rook g1 queen 27 and
now and Luke g4 yeah looking at the
fourth-ranked covering the pawn covering
f4 certainly logical the also could have
played rook g5 in this position that was
discussed in the in the broadcast but
probably ultimately it doesn't lead to
all that much after g6 yeah it was
playable but then hawkins move cannot be
criticized now you can improve that
Chris and everything but not justifiably
it's it's a good choice yeah now the
route went to h4 after Knight f6 and
looks a little bit exotic the rook
placement but it serves the purpose so
it covers the pawn and is this active
there um yeah difficult I mean I really
don't see why black would want to play
this position somehow somewhat strange
that we that we got to go to this here
yeah it hasn't played the move Queen
should be five which looks quite logical
looking at this Bishop and of course
attacking the rook and yeah kind of he
went back to a 1 by the way I'm not
saying that black is in terrible shape
that's not the case it just feels cats
kind of strange why you would want to
play this position somehow I am if you
wire a line where this kind of situation
can happen and ok route a 1mm and now g6
yeah that's a move that's it's difficult
to play it to play without it in the
long run it's really difficult to do you
need some space for the king and
potentially um get this also secures
square one f5 this is something that we
will see see you later for the night for
example and black couldn't couldn't do
this tactic here there is root chicks
cuckoo chicks chicks and at the end
there is the back rank that will kill
you check another reason why giving the
king some space makes sense yeah g6
useful move rupee one playback reaction
now the Queen has to move again and
cleaned III also quite logical getting
the Queen to an active spot and it is
the g6 pawn which looks at first a
little bit mystifying why is that
important but if you spot the bishop
here you're always whenever and it's a
very important point for practical play
whenever you have a king on g8 or g1 and
there's this Bishop pointed at your king
on the defending side always keep in
mind that this is pennant the f porn can
never take on g6 so then this is
screened III is kind of saying you know
I'm going to do something on g6
attention there so whenever this kind of
situation happens make sure to check out
if there are some tactics against this
pawn and something will happen later
with there with those tactics and Bishop
g5 also was a movie air form for white
but black has a good reply 832 f5 I
think that was my notes say right yeah
exactly Queen f5 and I try to do it
without looking at it all that much but
sometimes I'm not quite sure what I
would I wrote down yeah a black and put
the night here and this is fine it's
fine it's blocking and this is a an
interesting position whenever why it has
to by the way take here in most cases
black will be fine even a paw down
because the blockade on d5 is so strong
that why does not get in getting forward
all that much now you have the pawn you
have a pawn up but all pawns are weakish
and this is probably a non attempt for
white to win I think I I can play this
correctly cunha free is a good move and
yeah 95 that blockade and rook g1 here
we come g6 g6 if Black now has to be
alert I mean it's not difficult to see
but you have to have to be a cautious
Bishop c7 play D aren't happening an eye
on this and Bishop g5 now was played and
it not a bad move rook h5 was an
alternative here just putting the rukon
the fifth-ranked and putting pressure on
the night and yeah here on the world
champion would have had to ask some to
answer please answer some some some
serious question what what he should do
now and you have to do something with
the night you protected somehow and
Queen c6 and 26 come into considerations
both both are not the decision is not
easy to make if you go Queen c6
there is rook see one now again asking
some questions what is black supposed to
do now you can actually play this month
because rooty five is now failing you
two made and if you take with the bishop
you can actually take the rook this is a
funny funny continuation very technical
Bishop takes now if the King takes
checks is actually winning for white
oops rope here's the concluding move so
black would have to move the king and
yeah it leads to wild complication
something like that it's very
interesting and tough to analyze and
black is probably not using here but
playing this is another matter and why
it has a very simple winning idea Queen
you seven probably holds but tough
alternatively I'm thousand could have
opted for Queen to e6 in this case this
is maybe better but it's not so easy to
do this because this is a very sensitive
diagonal and your kind of reluctant to
put a piece another piece in this
diagonal yeah even this is an
interesting idea now but yeah we'll put
in my notes a i think a fire actually
even and five is possible him but i mean
it's it's a move that the engine does
not refute like outright and it's this
is difficult to play for both sides but
black is under pressure Luke h5 was an
interesting movie about Bishop g5 is
also it's nothing that that you can fold
okay I can afford to play it also has a
funny funny idea and Luke we ain't now
was played oh wow
I think my friend s so this is and the
rookie a tie the line that needs to be
mentioned is if black takes the Queen
yeah White has check this grin off again
whenever this happens be alert g6 is
weak now this is a funny line and now
this mate cannot be prevented that's
pretty nice black doesn't even have a
check here to to prolong prolong it it's
just like made in two moves and it is
very important whenever this happens pay
extra attention to the point on g6 this
helps you to spot ideas like this
clicker so that was a little trap but of
course easy to see four players of that
level so can't move the rook correctly
and queen to see form more pressure on
the night and the rupee five protects it
and keeps the blockade intact on d5 a
funny situation Bishop a for now looked
good but this actually is leading
nowhere because of the good move Queen
to f5 all of a sudden there is a counter
play white skin position is a little bit
shaky and here a special name
interesting is a line what was the line
precise lame and yeah actually Queen to
f1 going going back keeping keeping the
skewer intact here rook be one is a
great move that black hands it's really
funny cakes kiss him and now all of a
sudden 93 black is the rook down and all
kinds of things are hanging but she
seems to be fine after something like
winter at 194 he is down a full exchange
but the white position is so badly
coordinated that black is actually ok
here white has a hard time to get to get
any sort of coordination going yeah we
see a pin here the back the back rank is
weak and black the threatening to to
activate even further so that was
aligned where bloggers is far
a cracking played clean to see two and
now and probably a move that put cards
and ends of slide trouble I think he
played this well yeah I mean both sides
played well but I think cars in this
slightly uncomfortable position was
doing a good job and here before
probably was the move to keep this
position level yeah keeping I mean he
had to do something about the Bishop f4
idea so he played rukka 8 to address
that but i think would before was this
was called moves route before was
probably a bit better and ultimately
difficult for y to make any any progress
um something like and what is the line
he had bishops before I think wasn't
wasn't idea here yeah well you have to
see if white is something like that
again Black has to be on the lookout for
several things here that would actually
win for white or close to winning it can
be can be it can be analyzed but again
do you don't want to do that but here
this is possible keeping this diagonal
oops sorry that was a completely wrong
paint keeping that diagonal blocked by
the night and attacking of this and if
white has to take now like it will be
fine as mentioned if this trade happens
Black is usually totally okay having
enough compensation because of the bad
white structure yeah look before was
probably the move that keeps the
position equal you play through a 8 and
now he isn't slight trouble again
because this is kind of happening almost
bare force luke a one makes mech sensor
with the rook their double check and
yeah here this helped watch a little bit
yeah that the drug trade but still
there's nothing particularly wrong with
black situation we decide to the disgust
fact that he is like under on the
defensive for the whole time and
probably he should play what the engines
has suggested he a bishop to d8 and just
continue from here keep the position as
is and what he did is looking logical
strategically but has a tactical flaw
Carlton played two moons 97 he was down
to two minutes now so that was all a bit
under time pressure yeah he had 97 this
is one of the absolute critical
situations of this is a critical
situation w of this game and maybe and
also for the whole match situation
because kayaking was leading by one
point before the game and a second win
wouldwould is the end of the match if he
leads by two points and i think carlton
i cannot come back from that in three
games nobody can probably not even a
computer and anyway so 97 plate and
kayaking clearly sensed that something
as is possible now and he took here 27
minutes on the clock I think this is a
fairly accurate what we have displayed
him he took 25 or 25 26 minutes now of
his remaining time to trying to figure
out how we can play from this position
and there are two main museum and the
first move is the one that he ultimately
played that is Bishop takes f7 check
second move is going to be three
attacking the porn on f7 the thing is
there is a vulnerability currently on
for black he has many pieces on the same
rank and Bishop takes f7 if we start at
least start with this move and we see
that for example after the capture this
is part of the position and everything
is on the same rank this is especially
important in the queen bee three line so
he played in Bishop f7 at the end but
let's look at Queen to be three this is
the choice by the engines and
as typical nowadays there was to stick
this future out crime and when kayaking
didn't didn't play out there and but you
have to see that the lines that are
connected with this move as so
outlandish that it's very difficult from
human to play this move ready ok we'll
see we'll see what the lines are because
of what F 7 is hanging Lex reply here is
basically force he has signal 9 f five
now the point of all this is that why I
can capture on f7 check this is a
clearly something that parking has
calculated and now we have to see that
black actually has two moves you can
take the bishop or play King g7 now King
g7 is interesting because it leaves
everything hanging the rope here we'll
check the pawn and the bishop is still
also i mean there's route takes h7 has
an idea but here all kinds of things are
hanging so both moves are possible now
let's see what ki can certainly
calculate it he calculated the capture
i'm very sure their paycheck takes 10
yeah and now we see that if black plays
Knight g7 Bishop h6 is fairly easy to
see how good this is for why'd you get
the piece back you should you should win
this rather comfortably with with extra
points so it's the king move takes and
now I'm yeah black can take on d4 or
check I think the check was better let
me check let me check the check yeah the
check was better check check and take
him so this is not I mean white very
likely should win this position but it
is not it is not technically completely
trivial because of the very bad porn
structure we have to see that it's two
pawns but these are all week but still
if kayaking
see this position he's certainly happy
to go for it so I ask you that this must
have been part of his calculation the
problem however is that black also has
King g7 which might be objectively
weaker but this is very difficult to
manage for human now because like
everything is hanging and don't
underestimate then in some weird cases
even the White King can be somewhat
problematic the rookie is covering this
and yeah so let's look at this King g7
and the look is attacked Brooke h3 is
it's kind of clear that you have to do
that here you cannot you cannot move the
route back here then the bishop eggs so
you have to be on the edge file to be
always ready form check for this tactic
so Lucas reassess the only move and now
black can play this 27 and it's
something that you have to really look
at with the human I don't think about
what the computer is telling you about
queen bee three lack of this Vince blah
blah blah look at this position and try
to figure out yourself seeing this now
if this is easy or not first of all you
see that the bishop is still somewhat
hanging on f7 it's something that you
need to think about if you move the
Queen for example you know why your
white queen on b3 is kind of limited and
so it's not like totally easy to find a
good move here also if you lose the
default point back your port structure
means that your extra corn is worth
absolutely nothing black might threaten
night h4 here winning the exchange back
then your King has no squares so what to
make of this the best move in this
position pointed out by the engine is
Bishop to g8 see this is already not
trivial at all but it gets it gets more
ridiculous
the next most first of all you you have
to calculate that the scales which is
doable really so for those pairs is
definitely doable check this will
ultimately win for white but this more
and now your hook here is stuck
absolutely stuck and the only move that
does something now for white is the most
d5 closing this diagonal letting the
bishop g8 kind of hang okay there is d6
check it's clear that here it's clear
that this is working but well there's
also night to deform and this is these
are not situations that are extremely
difficult to assess note that let's say
why play something something's now in 4k
it's very difficult to say what what
what stupid movie should play he only
has bishops III actually yeah if you
move the Queen I mean your bishop is
hanging and I mean if black let's say
gets to play this and this is made this
is an extremely difficult position to
assess bishops III Bishop b5 and now
what has to play d6 crazy it's totally
crazy Quincy five check rook g3 hooray
yeah you know this is very easy to see
ya when you look at queen bee three we
already seven moves deep and this
continues this continues and ultimately
this shouldn't work for black but to see
this before and with white is it's just
impossible can I mean not in a knot in a
situation like that yeah in the world
championship match where where you're
reading one point and that's completely
unrealistic so kaya can have to head
this choice you could play queen bee
three with this very difficult to assess
situation or play sorry that was a
little bit much here or play Bishop F
as it turns out and Bishop f7 doesn't do
it yeah so that was a was an opportunity
I mean purely from a mathematical sense
that was a the second-best or bad move
Bishop a seven but you cannot afford
anybody there he took 25 minutes to
figure this out and it's extremely
difficult really extremely difficult
especially this valve variation you know
you overlook something and you might
lose the game I mean this is terrible if
you if white would lose this game due to
some kind of miss evaluation such a such
a weird line when the alternative is
Bishop of seven which is lets you
material first and foremost yeah so okay
it took on that sound checks have a look
yeah no choice has to take and check
check here yeah this is not leading to
anything yeah white can actually take
here and get an ending here with with 44
points for peace but this is not going
to be anything black and probably draw
with the night shake or Bishop f4 the
pawns are just completely the structure
is totally wrecked you will not be able
to promote something here so we play it
correctly Queen ac4 check the King had
to move and now we've got to move 40
time control okay I can plate d5 this is
what he had calculated and when you have
to see this right and he calculated this
line where is a piece down at the moment
but he threatening bishops III check I
mean it was a great calculation job to
took to come to this point and and and
assess that correctly he is quite quite
funny and where we have an interesting
instance of or how we can look at
computer chess in a way and the
computer now condemns Carl's let's move
on he played nine f5 and wants him to
play the move g5 yeah and under those
circumstances I can absolutely assure
you no no player will play g5 this
completes a completely wacky line g5
check check King g6 you have to
appreciate this is hanging this is
hanging check the Queen you for change
this and then move right okay Queen you
can check Queen f5 and look it before
threatening Group A for really funny
right like these six takes takes check
Queen g4 check kingdom one push up here
and this is what the engine wants to
play and things this is better than the
game however in the game we will see
that cards and holds reasonably
comfortably so the engine here is this
wants to play something that for the
human players like give me more than
scary to play g5 this is Carlos and this
is correct it's a correct decision the
next moves are basically forced why it
has to make sure that he gets the look
there on a one check and this is coming
on the board know by force so YT is a
pawn up but it's a double pawn and
what's very important to him blacks
position is reasonably well coordinated
he's got this pawn lon light squares and
usually those can be easily defended by
the Queen the Queen sitting on d7 f7
sometimes on f5 and he's got he's got
his pieces working together quite quite
well why can actually do nothing with
his porn check yeah
ky ky yakin but there's really very
little that chicken cheney here in this
situation he could have played Bishop f6
which would have led to the white pawn
structure being improved but this is in
fact very simple to draw black puts the
key 1e6 looking at the f5 Square and
this would be the square where white
needs to pushes pawn due to get a passer
and blackish is preventing that this is
a fortress type of position where white
has absolutely nothing yeah okay i can
now decided to continue for a little bit
i mean he has absolutely zero danger
here black it's also also quite gentle
to hold for carbon I mean the only
raishin use this position would be just
to blunder stuff I mean blunder material
and channel it's difficult to do here
because yeah check it is so so easy and
black as well coordinated this is an
important thing black should not trade
into a green end and Queen a porn ending
this is I mean it's also a draw don't
get me wrong but here at least White has
some potential ideas connected with
playing fy5 at the right moment and
maybe yeah pick up one of the then then
split pawns shouldn't happen if black is
carefully but he can at least do
something wrong with the bishops on the
board we just have a complete complete
fortress in a way yeah can't so a couple
of more moves and here a draw was agreed
actually wonder really I wonder it's a
little bit uncommon that this is a black
move it would be strange of cars on
offer to draw here and anyway that's not
another real point of this game so it
may be kayaking mr. chance there with
the queen bee three being rejected but
that was a very very difficult situation
to assess we seen the really a wacky
computer lines that are very
human to calculate especially especially
considering the circumstances yeah he
certainly he had Bishop f7 worked out
and now I understand why he played that
the other line was very devout there was
some very outlandish moves and also
potentially those lights actually
contained risk of losing and that that's
certainly something that you don't want
to happen the situation so three games
left to white games for cars I still
think he has reasonable chances to to
come back into the match but it's it's a
little time it's a little time three
games it's not a lot so we'll see what
happens today what he plays with the
white pieces and that college system
didn't lead anywhere and would be
interesting to see what he what he comes
up with ok guys thanks for watching and
yeah I'll be back with the coverage I by
the way after they have to have to tell
you I'm not not quite sure i'll be back
is good and i'm not quite sure about my
coverage of the next games because i'll
be away on the weekend for playing the
tournament myself so i might be able to
do something i'm going to take the
notebook with me but i cannot really
promise that it that it that it will
work that i can post something maybe
this will be until sunday sunday evenin
that I continue my coverage I'm not
quite sure about it we'll see what
happens thanks a lot for watching bye
bye